Speaker 1: And finally, another Elon Musk story
to finish off today's program. Elon Musk has said
that he will support Ron DeSantis for president
in 2024 if the Florida governor decides to run
for president. Earlier this year, Musk followed in
the footsteps of people like Dave Rubin and Tulsi
Gabbard, who were supposedly on the left before,
but then drifted more and more to the right for
one reason or another. And people often question
the genuineness of these transformations. Elon has
now joined them. He's previously said that he's
voting Republican and his followers should do the
same because that would lead to divided government
after the 2022 midterms to, quote, curb the worst
excesses of. Of both parties. The real reason, of
course, that billionaires like Musk, like divided
government, is because it provides some certainty
that nothing is going to get done legislatively,
at least nothing major is going to get done.
And it's good for their stock prices because
it just goes to show that the boat is not going
to get rocked. Elon was asked in a tweet whether
he'd back to Santos if he decides to run for
president, and he said yes. Going on to say
my preference for the 2024 presidency is someone
sensible and centrist. I had hoped that would be
the case for the Biden administration, but have
been disappointed so far, so to say that this
is apparently sensible and centrist or at least
much more sensible and centrist than Joe Biden
is. That's according to Elon Musk. I mean, how
delusional is that? Like you have Ron DeSantis,
who is at the center of every right wing
culture war issue, from trans people to
immigration to police to voter fraud. He's far
right and all of these things. And yet Biden,
who was perhaps the most conservative option
Democrats had in the 2020 primaries, who was,
you know, centrist Barack Obama's vice president,
he's too far left, apparently, that's really
trying to push the Overton Window in a rightward
direction, if you ask me. I don't think that Elon
actually thinks this, to be honest. I think that
he recognizes that his fan base is mostly right
wing and he fell victim to audience capture
like so many people do. He's just telling his
crowd what they want to hear. And, you know, he
just assesses that Republican control also will
be good for his net worth, at least for the short
term. So he's just pushing right wing figures like
the Santas. He also probably assesses, though,
that Trump may be past his prime and it's better
for him to distance himself more and more from
Trump, because at this point, you know, especially
defending Trump is just becoming more and more
untenable. So there you go. Elon Musk is falling
squarely into the DeSantis camp, which a lot of
Republicans have found themselves doing recently,
because many are trying to look more sensible.
They're trying to pick the more decent option out
there in someone like the Santas who has all of
Trump's policy stances but is presented a lot more
neatly. And we'll have to see how the endorsements
shake out, whether this cohort of people who
choose to Santos over Trump will end up making a
difference, especially someone like Elon, who has
a cult like following. And many of his people will
decide to go the distance this route because Elon
is doing it and it's definitely shaping up to be
a battle for the ages. That's for sure. All right.
That's going to do it for today's episode of The
David Pacman Show. For more content, be sure to
check out today's bonus show if you are already
a member or patron, if you're not yet a member
or a patron become one. Might as well write. You
could go to join Pacman dot com and sign up for a
membership or you could contribute over at Patriot
at the $5 level to become able to access the bonus
show. We'll see you all there and have.
Unidentified: A great day, everybody.